there is there is a way for any
individual to do that I got this insight
about seven years ago when I bought
stock in a company and shortly after and
in the price at which I bought it kind
of by definition was some sort of
discounted present value of a consensus
future flow of cash in that company
after I bought it the company made some
statements reported some results and
essentially the market reassessed the
growth prospects of the company
realizing gosh these guys are given get
bigger than we thought faster than we
thought and so the prize pot and then I
bought stock at that new price and the
company then executed on that newly
foreseen growth trajectory and the stock
price didn't move because that new
growth trajectory already was discounted
into the this higher prize and so it it
it helped me see that the only way a
company can have its share price
continually outperform the market is if
they keep surprising the market on the
upside oh my gosh there's even more
growth here than we thought hey
everybody come and look there's even
more growth here than we thought it's
the only way a company's stock can
outperform the market is through upsides
upside surprises and then I realized
that just as the established companies
systematically underestimate how big
disruptive companies will become Wall
Street's methods of financial analysis
systematically undervalue disruptive
companies and how big they will become
and so it's disruptive companies that
are the ones that keep surprising the
market on the upside oh my gosh there's
even more growth here than we thought
and so my son and I just were not
wealthy people but we just decided that
we would invest our family's assets with
an idiot simple algorithm that is if
disruptive by when they hit the high end
of the market
and over the subsequent six years that
portfolio generated a compounded annual
return of 36 percent with no leverage no
hedging no shorting just if disruptive
by when they hits the high end of the
market cell yeah
and that's something that really anybody
with just a average income like me can
actually profit quite handsome